all right so let's speak i was talking
about to change the subject completely
turner classics they're the movie
i like turner classics okay i once did a
thing for them um and they
but of course in this new era they had
to reframe the classic so they have to
have a guy come on
at the beginning yeah see there it is
i'm not i'm not lying
um and give a little speech about why
movies that you used to just enjoy
because you understood you understood
the times change
people change and more race change it's
called evolution but now
it's called problematic anyway so we
yes it's so it's so obvious you know
um and gone with the winds is on the
list breakfast at tiffany's
my fair lady my fri my fair lady is too
rough for them
it was too corny for me when i was 10.
my father wanted me to go see it i
wouldn't okay
so uh but those aren't just the only
movies would you like to see some of the
other ones that they have to give
warnings to now the classics oh i'm sure
you would
these are some of the other ones i don't
think these really need warnings but
they have it sleeping beauty
a prince kisses an unconscious woman
without consent see there
it is
the wizard of oz a powerful woman of
color is murdered by a rural white girl
[Applause]
psycho inaccurately portrays the lives
of the vast majority of transgender
motel owners
[Applause]
uh rosemary's baby fails to present
planned parenthood as a viable
option
[Applause]
jaws portrays white people as victims
wrong
the graduate depicts a problematic age
discrepancy that you can't blame on the
man
uh the oh look the greatest story ever
told
yes warning portrays in a positive light
a power imbalance
between mary a palestinian teenager and
god a more powerful man
and of course braveheart warning stars
mel gibson
you